colombia's most wanted drug lord and
gang leader is behind bars soldiers
captured dairo antonio usaga in an
operation near the border with panama
he's accused of drug trafficking murder
and kidnapping
colombia's most wanted caught in his
jungle hideout dairo antonio usuga known
as otoniel eluded authorities for years
alias
was the most feared narco-trafficking
leader in all the world
of police officers
soldiers
social leaders
a recruiter of children
yes
this is only paralleled by the fall of
pablo escobar in the 1990s
the operation to capture ottoniel
involved more than 500 soldiers and
special forces the narco trafficker is
accused of spending decades building the
so-called gulf clan cartel controlling
much of the smuggling of cocaine through
northern colombia
over those years he allied himself with
rebel groups both right and left wing to
ensure his survival in the jungle he
allegedly oversaw an army of assassins
who kept northern colombia in fear as
they fought for control of lucrative
smuggling roots
capturing o'tooniel is a victory for the
state and the rule of law against the
biggest threat in colombia drug
trafficking
that may be but otoniera's arrest comes
amid a surge in the production of cocoa
the raw material used to make cocaine to
new levels despite decades of efforts to
eradicate the drug trade
and for more or less let's go to bogota
and talk to sergio guzman in the
colombian capital he's the director of
the columbia risk analysis
a political risk consultancy for the
andean region uh mr guzman authorities
have been hunting ortega for years what
was the final piece of the puzzle that
led to his arrest
good morning and it's wonderful to be
here i think
the colombian authorities have for
decades been trying to infiltrate the
clandell golfo put out uh rewards that
lead to the capture or killing of many
of these drug kingpins and this is
definitely suggests that intelligence
apparatus is working in colombia
and and can you tell us more about this
clan del golfo is this the end of it uh
as
the president was sort of intimating now
that his boss is behind bars
by no means is it the end of it nor is
it the end of the war on drugs as we
know it in fact we've been here before
this situation has played out again
president said this is the most
important killing since the death of
pablo escobar which didn't bring down
drug trafficking instead it diversified
drug trafficking from pablo escobar to
lower kingpins down the road
and that's exactly what's going to
happen in this case
so there are the lower uh
level kingpins as you were saying who
are going to sort of uh take up take up
the business
absolutely as long as their demand
coming from europe from the united
states from the rest of south america
for cocaine we are going to see a new
kingpin emerge will he be a better more
sophisticated more cruel kingpin than
not only we're about to see that
and otonia apparently had links to
far-right and left-wing gorillas
so what does this mean for colombia's
peace process which is was
has been in the making for decades and
quite fragile at times
yes
the
right-wing auto offenses guytanistas the
colombia which which are also known as
the clan del golfo had been killing
social leaders had been eroding the rule
of law in rural areas
that was definitely negative for the
progress of the peace process and the
implementation of things such as land
reform political rights for former
victims and justice but
what
what is going to come of this may be a
deeper penetration by mexican cartels
maybe the formation of a new
organization that is going to continue
making vulnerable people or people who
are already vulnerable will remain so
until
we are able to address the drug war from
the root of the cause which is demand
for drugs and an economic issue of
inequality here in colombia
okay sergio guzman in bogota thanks so
much
great to see you thank you
and for more on this let's go to bogota
and talk to elizabeth dickinson senior
analyst at the crisis group for colombia
her work centers on around armed
conflict dynamics in the country ms
dickinson we understand this was a
massive operation going on for years can
you tell us what the final piece of the
puzzle was that led to the arrest
well i think
what we've heard about the operation is
that it was underway and being planned
for several months before it took place
certainly this is a person that and
colombian military intelligence would
have been looking for really for years
we're talking about an individual who
has had a leading role in the drug trade
and in armed criminal activity for
decades uh really for three decades in
various iterations and this most latest
perhaps one of the most important
particularly since the 2016 peace accord
between colombia and the farc group
for our gravel group
viklanda golfo the organization that
otto nail was running really took
advantage of that agreement to
consolidate space and feel some of the
vacuums that the park left behind so
they've really grown and grown in
influence and so certainly this is a
very significant arrest
we were just hearing that the president
sounds confident the spell's the end of
the cartel with the boss behind bars do
you think that's true
unfortunately not and and i think this
is one of the patterns that we've seen
recently emerge in colombia's conflict
is that often in a situation like this
and after there is a big capture you
will see a sort of turf war a battle for
control of what's left the spoils of the
business thereafter this is particularly
worrying in the current situation
because this is an armed group that
already had significant splits within it
now otunia was such a powerful figure
that he was able to mostly unify those
splits but i think we should all be very
concerned and be watching closely to see
the sort of in fallout from this arrest
in terms of competition within the armed
group that could lead to violent feuds
this is an organization that uses
violence really um
without consideration to the civilian
cost
and so it's very worrying in terms of
what it could signify signify for the
regions of colombia where this group is
active
and you were talking about the peace
process earlier particularly with the
farc rebels now tonight apparently had
links with both sides far right far left
correct me if i'm wrong i mean what does
his arrest mean for the fragile process
so the peace process in 2016 with the
farc i think was really a game changer
for colombia because it really it
demonstrated that negotiation is the
off-ramp to all of the conflicts that
are taking place in colombia now otto
neil has a very interesting history in
the conflict in this regard because as
you said he was a bit of a pragmatist at
the chameleon changing sides when it was
convenient for him and one of those
iterations was actually to seek
negotiations with the government
ultimately the government decided this
is more of a criminal organization than
any sort of political movement the
negotiations didn't go forward but i
think moving ahead what we have to think
about is really how to deconstruct the
dynamics of the conflict and really
negotiation is one of the only and best
options that doesn't involve a civilian
cost
okay elizabeth dinkinson thanks so much
for that insight
you